madame monsieur bonsoir c'est ici même
que la nuit dernière à ce prix de 500 km
de téhéran dans une zone presque
désertique du territoire iranien que
l'opération montée par les états unis
pour délivrer les otages de l'ambassade
à téhéran a échoué deux appareils
faisant partie du commando se sont
télescopés au sol sur un aérodrome
clandestins au cours d'une opération de
ravitaillement alors que le président
carter avait déjà annulé l'opération
pour des raisons techniques trois
hélicoptères en panne on n'en sait pas
plus pour l'instant bilan huit morts et
plusieurs blessés les états unis
affirmant que tous les membres du
commando ont pu être évacués d'iran
voilà pour les faits qui sont loin
d'être claires et sur lesquels nous
reviendrons tout à l'heure en détail la
nouvelle à laquelle personne ne
s'attendait et dont les conséquences
sont encore difficilement appréciable a
été annoncée en pleine nuit par le
président américain qui s'était ensuite
dès 7 heures du matin heure américaine
adressé à son peuple un discours de six
minutes à peine prononcée par un homme
visiblement épuisée et tendu dans lequel
il n'a pas donné beaucoup d'informations
mais prenons le soin de bien préciser
qu'il s'agissait pour lui d'un échec
bien évidemment toute l'amérique
attendait ce discours les américains
humilié comme l'a dit l'ancien président
nixon qui craint que son pays fasse
l'objet d'humiliations encore plus
important à la suite de cet échec
humiliation mais aussi peur que les
otages ne fasse les frais de ce fiasco
bien que pour l'instant les autorités
iraniennes frêche plutôt la modération
et tourne en ridicule l'échec du
commando américain au moment même où le
président carter prononcer son discours
le correspondant d'antenne 2 aux états
unis se trouvait au milieu d'une famille
dont le père attaché culturel à téhéran
fait partie des otages de l'ambassade
lui mort et tout cela pour quoi prions
dieu pour que les iraniens fassent
preuve de modération face à cette
situation
elle avait été la réaction de la famille
de grève la nuit dernière à une heure du
matin dès l'annoncé de l'échec stupeur
abattement et indignation puisque ce qui
était redouté de plus d'une semaine
l'intervention militaire allait s'avérer
désastreux
désolant surtout que ces jeux truies
jeunes 16 en ouverture pour rien ou
encore une fois et que cela empire est
de nouveau la situation étant sion
contrairement à ce que ces cartes un
semblable 30 en iran
et que
encore une fois malgré son engagement
par la voix de certains diplomates et du
secrétaire d'état wendt représenté par
nous serons nous avait confirmé hier
soir à entière soir qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'action militaire que qu'il n'en était
pas question et que ce serait seulement
après consultation avec le congrès que
ça aurait lieu
malgré ce que dit le président est
évident que c'était tout de même une
opération militaire de ce fait le
président a
vraiment
il n'a pas il n'a pas respecté le délire
du peuple américain a exprimé par le
congrès qu'aucune action militaire
n'aurait lieu sans à consultation et de
ce fait je pense qu'il faut avant tout
transmettre par la voix qu'on peut parce
que nous n'avons pas réussi par
téléphone on nous coupe même de france
on coupe on ne peut pas transmettre le
message aux iraniens et cette décision
était uniquement celle du président
carter et nom du peuple américain et
qu'uniquement le président carter et
responsable est quand même si on nous a
parlé je crois qu'il fallait porter ce
qui a été fait
l'américain était honnête patients et
les américains que les iraniens
malhonnête
nous avons fait ce qu'il fallait faire
c'était la seule chose
je sens ça ne fait pas notre habileté
habituel j'espère qu'on aura plus de
chance la prochaine fois
je ne m'attendais pas l'opération
militaire et je suis triste pour les
huit américains qui ont été tués
un jour de tristesse
quant à fiat pour carter comment il va
le payer très cher car il a agi pour des
motifs électoraux
après cette réaction à chaud de
l'amérique que vous venez d'entendre les
faits donc maintenant personne jusqu'à
présent à washington n'a vraiment
expliquer clairement ce qui s'était
passé cette nuit en iran on connaît
simplement le bilan huit morts dans une
collision au sol en territoire iranien
entre deux appareils qui faisait partie
du commando un commando spécialisé dans
ce type d'intervention avec un matériel
bien particulier que nous allons voir à
l'entraînement sur ces images d'archivés
commentées par patrick clément
ce genre d'opérations secrètes est menée
par des hommes particulièrement autres
aînés qui ont à leur disposition un
matériel assez sophistiqués tels ce
modèle d'avion hercules c-130 qui peut
transporter sur plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres 5 à 6000 une quinzaine de
tonnes de matériel ou une centaine
d'hommes grâce à ses quatre
turbopropulseurs
ce sont des avions de ce type qui ont
été utilisés en iran pour le transport
du fameux commando us et de leur
matériel
ces hélicoptères qui sont filmés à fort
bragg ce sont les mêmes qui ont été
utilisés à tabac ce modèle qui peut
transporter une dizaine d'hommes et leur
équipement est identique à celui qui a
percuté en plein désert iranien les gros
porteurs dont nous parlions plus tôt
pour ce qui concerne l'opération tabasse
on croit savoir que la force américaine
était composé de trois gros porteur donc
de plusieurs hélicoptères et 300 hommes
participaient à l'opération huit sont ma
côté iranien on affirme que 50 autres
étaient laissées sur place washington
affirme de son côté que tous les
participants à l'opération ont quitté
l'iran pour l'instant aucune précision
n'a été donnée sur les bases de départ
américaine
première hypothèse le commando a pu
partir de turquie les c-130 hercules est
peuvent sans difficulté parcourir la
distance turquie iran deuxième
possibilité israël tout le monde sait
que les américains peuvent utiliser le
territoire israélien pour faire décoller
leurs avions troisième possibilité
l'egypte sadate a déclaré j'ai promis au
peuple américain d'accorder des
facilités pour la libération des otages
quatrième possibilité la flotte us qui
croisent dans l'océan indien enfin
cinquième hypothèse le pakistan mais
c'est la thèse est moins sérieux enfin
selon des sources venant de washington
l'opération sauvetage otages auraient
été annulés à partir de tabac à la suite
de défaillance technique sur trois des
hélicoptères participant à l'opération
monsieur harold brown de son côté
secrétaire de la défense affirme
qu'après cette défaillance technique un
hélicoptère et un avion sont entrés en
collision d'où les huit mois enfin cet
accident aurait pu se produire à cause
d'un brouillage organisé et fabriqué par
les soviétiques dont les installations
radar ne se trouve qu'à quelques
centaines de kilomètres au nord de tabac
oui la suite des événements si cet
accident n'avait pas eu lieu aurait pu
être la suivante selon le récit du moins
d'un agent de la cia services secrets
américains publiés aujourd'hui par le
magazine paris match le commando déposé
en territoire iranien déguisés en
paysans en homme de la rue aurait gagné
les abords de l'ambassade américaine de
téhéran ou après quelques jours
d'attenté il aurait donné l'assaut en
employant notamment des gaz soporifique
libérer les otages qui aurait ensuite
été évacué à bord d'hélicoptères peint
aux couleurs de l'armée de l'air
iranienne jusqu'à la base secrète
installée dans le désert au nord est de
téhéran de là le commando et les otages
libérés auraient été embarqués à
destination des états unis par petites
étapes
vous en doutez c'est la stupeur et
l'inquiétude qui règne aux états unis
depuis l'annnonce de cet échec aux
conséquences encore difficilement
appréciable sur le plan international
mais déjà à l'évidence très grave pour
le président carter washington jaksic un
jour de tristesse qui rappelle la baie
des cochons disent déjà certains
commentateurs quand il ya 20 ans le
président kennedy avait subi le même
échec en voulant envahir cuba quant aux
conséquences elles peuvent être
multiples naturellement sur le plan
intérieur la réélection carter peut être
déjà compromise remise en cause car une
nouvelle fois on va lui reprocher son
manque de cohérence
le sénateur frank cherche par exemple
fait remarquer que carter a déclenché
l'opération au moment même où les alliés
s'apprêtait à prendre des sanctions
économiques et diplomatique et on
redoute ici que la méfiance de ces mêmes
a lié sa croix puisque en quelque sorte
carter a caché son jeu puisqu'il ne les
a même pas informés de son initiative à
téhéran le ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur gods a dit à propos
de l'action entreprise par les
américains a parlé d'un acte de guerre
ce sont ses propres termes il a
toutefois demandé aux iraniens et
notamment aux étudiants islamiques qui
de garder garde les otages pardon de
conserver leur sang froid dans le même
temps dans les rues de téhéran la foule
laissait éclater sa joie serge nice
si le commando américain avait réussi à
atteindre le lit des questions il aurait
trouvé aucun otages vivent tous seraient
déjà en enfer c'est ce que vient de
déclarer l'ayatollah khomeiny est le
commentaire de cette foule amassée
devant l'ambassade américaine à téhéran
sous la conduite des ayatollahs est le
suivant c'est dieu qui a fait échouer
l'opération américaine
quant au président de la république
iranienne monsieur ben ali sadr voici ce
qu'il déclare et en revenant de tabac
les commandos américains ont tenté de
débarquer
il y avait cinq hélicoptères deux avions
détruits
pour mon moi j'ai pas d'autres
informations
c'est clair
la préoccupation majeure des iraniens
semblent donc apparemment pour l'instant
de tourner en ridicule les américains
tout en jugeant très sévèrement leur
tentative de libération par la force des
otages
comme nous le disait d'ailleurs déjà au
cours d'antenne de midi l'ambassadeur
d'iran à paris
c'est un échec total de monsieur cratère
demande et le peuple américain devant
ses alliés commencé à douter
de mon gouvernement
et s'éteint c'est une opération
tous les jeudis jeux congolais sq et ses
cow-boys
enfin aucun résultat parce que ça va
attiser la colère des étudiants
évidemment il met en danger la vie des
étudiants des otages et bien qu à
fortifier notre unité nationale
et il a justifié n'est ce pas les
opérations des étudiants viennent pas de
résultats seulement monsieur un cartel à
des lisiers de personnel il veut être
élu il ne veut pas sauver la vie des
otages il nous parle du mal à la racine
oui ce soir première intervention de
l'ayatollah khomeiny dans cette affaire
citée ce soir même donc par la radio
iranienne il lance un avertissement aux
états unis quant à l'avenir des otages
selon l'imam et ce sont ses propres
termes qui sont cités ci nouvelle
tentative stupide de libération des
otages américains détenus à l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran intervenait ni moi
même dit l'ayatollah ni le gouvernement
iranien ne saurions mesure garantir
l'attitude des étudiants qui détiennent
les otages des étudiants qui ont fait
savoir eux toujours dans une déclaration
à la radio iranienne que la prochaine
tentative se solderait par la mort des
otages
officiellement du moins personne dans le
monde ne semblait s'attendre à cette
opération américaine cet étonnement mais
monsieur andry gromyko le ministre des
affaires étrangères soviétique en voyage
en france n'a pu le dissimuler lorsque
la question lui a été posée au cours
d'une conférence de presse qu'il tenait
ce matin à paris avant son départ
quand j'ai appris la nouvelle ce matin
je dois dire que j'ai eu de la peine à
le croire
mais maintenant j'ai eu confirmation de
l'opération
ce que je peux dire c'est en ce qui
concerne en ce qui nous concerne nous
sommes opposés à toute action militaire
à toute alliance for rien des états unis
ou de tout autre pays qui conduisirent
voile alors vous êtes peut-être remarqué
le demi sourire de monsieur gromyko
franchement il y avait de quoi car dans
cette opération ratée l'urss en poche
des bénéfices assez considérable
premiers bénéfices dans la mesure où les
américains font qu'on le veuille ou non
figure d'agresseur et bien les
soviétiques font figure de défenseurs
potentiel des iraniens deuxième
bénéfices dans la mesure où les
américains sont tout de même un petit
peu ridicule avec ses histoires
d'hélicoptères et d'avions qui se
télescopent ou qu'ils tombent en panne
et bien cela fait rendre cela rend plus
majestueuse la force de l'armée
soviétique donc je le répète on comprend
le sourire du ministre souris roccat le
fait pendant d'ailleurs la violence de
la presse soviétique qui avec une
rapidité assez rare chez elle a
immédiatement déclenché une très vive
campagne contre monsieur carter
carter viole le droit international
disait ce matin radio moscou une
aventure sans précédent renchérit c'est
l'agent stas arrêter la folie titre ce
soir les izvestia il est bien évident
que les soviétiques ont grand intérêt à
déclencher cette campagne a accusé les
américains ce qui permettra et c'est le
troisième bénéfices ce qui permettra le
faire un petit peu oublier qu'ils ont eu
aussi quelques peccadilles à se
reprocher en afghanistan réaction encore
de monsieur valdan secrétaire général
des nations unies qui fait appel à la
retenue et à la raison dans la crise
iranienne et qui par la même occasion en
profite pour proposer ses bons offices
voyons maintenant qu'elle peut être
l'attitude des alliés des etats unis
dans cette affaire car dans son discours
le président carter a fait appel une
nouvelle fois à leur solidarité nos
hivers terre a posé la question à
monsieur coup de murville ancien
ministre du général de gaulle et
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale
vous savez je pense que la première
réaction des européens va être une
réaction de stupéfaction bien sûr inité
pour brand ça ils peuvent pas le
reprocher aux états unis et d'autre part
ce sera une réaction d'inquiétude
d'inquiétude de port devant un échec
parce que c'est un échec très grave pour
l'amérique que d'avoir manqué ce secours
et ensuite on se demande quelles
pourront être les répercussions alors
bien sûr les européens vont se passer
entre eux puisque le hasard des choses
fait qu'ils se rencontrent dimanche au
plus haut niveau c'est à dire au niveau
des chefs de gouvernement à à luxembourg
est ce que ça va les conduire à se poser
des questions sur la solidarité qu'ils
ont affichée avec les etats-unis en
prenant lundi dernier à luxembourg aussi
des décisions de de punir l'iran à leur
tour et en particulier pour ce qui
concerne la seconde étape de ces mesures
qui est prévue pour le milieu mais et
qui devrait aller jusqu'à l'interdiction
totale des relations économiques entre
les pays européens de l'ouest et et
l'iran voilà les je prends ce que l'on
peut dire pour le moment
l'ibpt le mans donc les alliés les états
unis n'avaient pas été mis au courant la
tentative de libération des otages
n'étaient pas les seuls d'ailleurs même
aux états unis et le monde politique
avait été tenue à l'écart le secret
avait été remarquablement bien gardé
comme en témoigne vous allez voir le
sénateur démocrate henry jackson
interrogé par jacques séguin monsieur
jackson qui est pourtant membre de la
commission des forces armées américaines
jack white vision c'est d'abord la
tristesse que je veux mentionner après
cet échec
sohn car les otages ne sont pas libérés
on n'a pas commencé la photo l'enquète
au congrès mais cela ne saurait tarder
et on évolue en être responsable
je vous dirai ce matin que le congrès
partage son isolement avec les alliés
puisque nous non plus à bompas était
très doux
puis cela dit on est pas d'accord du
tout sûr de la réaction du peuple
américain à cette action tenté par le
président carter réaction encore d'un
spécialiste si je puis dire monsieur
benelli tsar ambassadeur d'israël en
egypte de passage à paris à l'occasion
des 12 heures pour israël monsieur
benaïssa qui avait été l'un des
organisateurs de l'opération en tb dans
tout le monde se souvient mais qui elle
s'était soldée par contre par une
réussite complète
se donnera quelque chose en soit arrivé
là et c'est dommage qu'elle soit pas
c'est de cette façon là je suis sûr que
à la fois en egypte où je représente
israël et en israël on trouve la terre
la tristesse vous vous attribuez cet
échec un manque de chance et un manque
de préparation
une autre difficile bien sûr dans l'état
actuel de l'information savoir
exactement mais j'imagine enfin vous
savez en général dans ce genre
d'opération il faut vraiment eu beaucoup
de chance pour pouvoir réussir bien sûr
il faut le préparer c'est l'opération
est très minutieusement il faut avoir de
zorn l'acquittement etc mais il faut
voir également beaucoup de chance
on a l'impression que la chance a manqué
aux américains
puis en france les députés communistes
avaient demandé ce matin que le ministre
des affaires étrangères monsieur jean
françois poncet viennent donner la
position de la france à l'assemblée
nationale cette demande a été rejetée
une réaction française encore celle de
monsieur michel pinton délégué général
de l'udf pour qui à partir du moment où
les iraniens ont violé la règle du droit
international il était fatal que les
états unis bafouée finissent par
utiliser la force voilà donc pour les
faits les réactions que nous allons
laisser avons essayé de vous donner le
plus complètement possible bien que
cette affaire soit encore très très
mystérieux il faut maintenant pour
conclure ce dossier examiner quelles
peuvent être les conséquences de cette
opération de libération manqué des
otages tant sur le plan international
l'intérieur américain paul nahon
bien cet échec extrêmement grave
pourrait avoir plusieurs conséquences la
première en iran même où cette opération
ratée va contribuer sans aucun doute à
resserrer en ressouder si vous voulez
tout le peuple iranien autour de la
sphère des otages de l'ambassade bien
sûr depuis ce matin on ne demande pas à
teyran de dénoncer les visées
expansionnistes et impérialiste de
washington sans oublier aussi la menace
des étudiants islamiques qui ont répété
à plusieurs reprises qu'il exécuterait
leur otage si les américains tentaient
une quelconque opération militaire en
fait l'échec de cette opération conforte
en quelque sorte en iran même la partie
la plus extrémiste du gouvernement comme
unis et isole encore un peu plus les
modérés comme le président de la
république islamique monsieur banny sa
deuxième conséquence sur le plan
intérieur américain bien sûr l'échec de
l'opération pour des raisons techniques
pratiquement pour des raisons
d'intendance démontre la faiblesse du
dispositif militaire américain alors que
d'autres pays beaucoup moins puissant
soulevez-vous israël avec l'opération en
tb où la france sakho loisirs ont réussi
des opérations de sauvetage de ce genre
c'est en fait toute la crédibilité de
l'administration carter qui est en cause
alors comment les alliés des américains
pourront-ils désormais continue à croire
que washington continuera de protéger
les intérêts les occidentaux dans cette
région vitale du monde qu'est le golfe
persique et puis on comprend mieux aussi
les réserves et les hésitations de ces
derniers jours des européens à suivre
les yeux fermés les demandes de sanction
demandée par le président carter enfin
après l'échec de cette opération
les états unis vont sans doute vérifiez
tout leur système militaire ce qui
paradoxalement peu éloigné encore les
risques de guerre entre les deux
superpuissances lune et tente en ce
moment en position de faiblesse et
l'autre moscou qui bénéficie sans coup
férir de la malchance et des hésitations
du président carter mais attention
l'échec de cette opération rejaillira
sans aucun doute non seulement sur les
etats-unis mais aussi sur l'europe et le
reste du monde
le reste de l'actualité à la veille du
sommet européen de luxembourg
manifestation d'agriculteurs à paris en
province à paris plus de 1000
agricultrice venus de normandie ont
descendu les champs elysées aujourd'hui
pour demander la fixation et
l'augmentation par la même occasion des
prix agricoles à propos de cette réunion
de luxembourg dimanche le conseiller du
président de la république monsieur
jacques blot a indiqué que six bien sûr
les chefs d'état aborderont le problème
déprise agricole le principal problème à
débattre sera celui de la contribution
britannique au budget communautaire a pu
bien sûr on parlera aussi de cette
affaire iranienne
l'europe toujours est en train de
disparaître c'est ce qu'a dit monsieur
jacques chirac aujourd'hui au forum
organisé par radio monte carl et la
presse régionale la politique agricole
commune ne fonctionne plus les
responsables de cet échec sont les
britanniques affirme monsieur chirac
seconde journée de grève dans
l'enseignement en france une journée qui
semble avoir été aussi bien suivie que
celle d'hier dix mille personnes ont
défilé à paris d'autres manifestations
ont eu lieu en province demain ce sont
les parents d'élèves de la fédération et
cornec tenant verront pas leurs enfants
à l'école hier et aujourd'hui des
incidents aussi sur le campus
universitaire de caen ont fait 18
blessés parmi les policiers de nouveaux
incidents ont eu lieu en début d'après
midi aujourd'hui
augmentation de 7 centimes c'est arrivé
de tous les produits pétroliers à partir
de demain officielle en france le litre
de super passe à 3 francs 40 de
l'ordinaire à 3 francs 21
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de paris a ordonné ce matin un
complément d'information dans l' enquête
sur l'assassinât de monsieur de breuil
cet arrêt semble d'ailleurs donné au
juge d'instruction une mission très
large
puisque les termes de l'arrêt procéder à
toute audition interrogatoire
confrontation saisie et cetera c'est
peut-être la personnalité du nouveau
juge d'instruction qui permet de
comprendre ce qu'a voulu dire entre les
lignes la chambre d'accusation de la
cour d'appel de paris monsieur andré
chevalier qui a été désigné à 64 ans ena
montluçon il est conseillé la cour
depuis sont 14 c'est un magistrat d'une
très grande urbanité mais aussi un homme
de vieille école très scrupuleux d'une
netteté de réflexion qui est reconnu par
tout le palais mais c'est aussi un vieux
juge d'instruction qui connaît toutes
les ficelles il va siéger à la chambre
d'accusation il a tout pouvoir pour
inquiéter le le dossier de brouille
devient tous je viens à son dossier il
récupère toutes les pièces alors à
conseiller à la cour c'est un haut
magistrat sa nomination sa désignation
plus tôt permet à certains de penser
j'en suis que la chambre d'accusation a
envisagé l'audition des deux premiers
juges d'instruction de la sphère de
brosses c'est à dire monsieur guy floch
et mademoiselle landini qui sont disons
d'un grade inférieur au sien le
conseiller chevalier a donc tout le
temps qu'il jugera nécessaire pour mener
son enquête mais il y à 7000 pièces dans
la sphère dans le dossier de brouille
alors il est fort probable que le procès
de brouille prévu pour cet automne sera
retardé peut-être jusqu'au début de
l'été 80 oui mais dans le même temps
l'un des membres de la commission
parlementaire le député communiste
monsieur kalinski s'est étonné que le
président de la république monsieur
giscard d'estaing dans les circonstances
actuelles est envoyée monsieur
poniatowski en mission en pologne auprès
de monsieur guirec 6 millions de francs
en faux billets 28 personnes arrêtées
les policiers français viennent de
démanteler un réseau international de
faux monnayeurs des billets neufs ont
été découverts à paris il s'agit de
coupures de 100 et 500 francs français
de peseta espagnole de dollars
américains de francs cfa le trafic
durait paraît-il depuis plusieurs années
en italie pollution pétrolière dans le
pot nous en avons déjà parlé plusieurs
milliers de tonnes de pétrole se sont
répandus dans le fleuve à la hauteur de
la ville de pavie parcourant très
rapidement des dizaines de kilomètres en
direction de l'adriatique à l'origine de
cette pollution une brèche ouverte dans
un oléoduc un reportage des victoires
ici nous sommes à l'isola séraphine
c'est à dire au point crucial de la
lutte contre la pollution du pot la
nappe de pétrole a déjà parcouru une
cinquantaine de kilomètres et on
l'attend ici à cet endroit devant ce
barrage si la nappe de pétrole se
déversent effectivement à cet endroit on
pourra la bloquer et peut-être même la
neutraliser la rupture de l'oléoduc
s'est produite à la hauteur de pain vie
2000 tonnes de pétrole se sont déversés
dans le fleuve et puis à une vitesse de
4 kilomètres à l'heure la nappe de
pétrole a avancé vers crémone sans
atteindre d'ailleurs le barrage de
serafini si le pétrole passe l'obstacle
du barrage il ira jusqu'à l'adriatique
c'est le pire qui puisse arriver
voici déjà les traces de cette
catastrophe
ces images qu'on a déjà vu si souvent
d'autres lieux pétrole et goudron se
sont fixés sur les deux rives du pô un
poisson mort ce ne sera peut-être pas un
désastre mais il faudra bien nettoyer
mètre par mètre les rives du fleuve quoi
qu'il arrive par la suite
c'est un désastre on pouvait bloquer la
nappe de pétrole bien avant à un autre
endroit pourquoi ils ne l'ont pas fait
il faut le demander aux techniciens s'il
pleut ce sera un désastre
la nappe se déversera sur les rives et
dans les campagnes
c'est seulement dans l'avenir qu'on
pourrait évaluer les conséquences de
cette pollution sur la faune et la flore
aquatique mais le pot c'est aussi une
source de fertilité pour toute la
province pourra-t-on continuer à
irriguer les cultures avec de l'eau
polluée par le pétrole dans l'immédiat
la nappe de pétrole s'est immobilisée il
y un fort vent contraire mais que
va-t-il se passer dans les prochains
jours
ça dépend répond le responsable de
l'environnement de la province s'il
pleut le fleuve peu gonflé la nappe de
pétrole va reprendre sa course on a déjà
perdu quatre jours on pouvait bloquer le
pétrole bien avant
à la question y aura-t-il un désastre
écologique le responsable de
l'environnement a répondu oh vous savez
les désastres écologiques
il en a tous les jours en italie c'est
sans doute exagéré mais c'est vrai que
la rupture de l'oléoduc de pavie pouvait
être prévu éviter éternel imprévoyance
écologique
et puis encore une catastrophe aérienne
cette fois ci très grave 146 personnes
sont portées disparues à bord d'un avion
d'une compagnie de charters britanniques
qui s'est abîmé dans les eaux
territoriales espagnol quelques minutes
avant son atterrissage sur l'aéroport de
tenerife aux canaries enfin dernière
information décès aujourd'hui à paris du
poète cubain alejo carpentier qui est
décédé dans son domicile paris la météo
pour terminer demain après la
dissipation des brouillards matinaux du
bassin aquitain
le ciel sera généralement ensoleillé sur
la moitié sud du pays les vents de nord
resteront assez fort dans la vallée du
rhône et près de la méditerranée
sur la moitié nord la matinée sera très
nuageuse et de petites pluies seront
possibles près des côtes la manche au
cours de la journée des éclaircies se
développeront les températures varieront
peut
demain soir édition spéciale organisée
par la rédaction d'antenne 2 bien sûr à
propos de cette affaire de cet échec de
la tentative de libération des otages en
iran et dans ce contexte troublé je vous
annonce tout de suite n'oubliez pas la
journée de lundi journée soviétique de
la rédaction d'antenne 2 avec les deux
journaux 13h et 20h en direct de moscou
et puis le soir question de temps
également réalisé en direct d'union
soviétique ce soir le dernier journal
vous sera présentée par paul amar nous
essaierons de vous faire un nouveau
bilan de cet échec américain en iran
demain samedi et demi jean claude
mongeau lui sera dans un tout autre
domaine mais il en faut en direct de la
première fois du modélisme à paris voilà
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
malgré ces événements inquiétants dont
nous avons parlé ce soir une excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir